i got so much nfl news that i want to
just just dive right into it and no one
better
to dive into it is ian rappaport of the
nfl network and
and i i kind of let me start with here
first because i know you've been
tweeting about some of the protocols
upcoming because we kind of turn our
attention now
from the free agency beginnings to now
the draft and so
the draft now has i'm seeing some new
protocols
for vaccinations and how they will
handle the covet and
inviting fans out to the to the draft
yeah um good to be with you so the the
sort of change came this morning
um you know from the nfl basically
regarding
uh updated guidelines from the cdc for
people who are
fully vaccinated um so you know
obviously fully vaccinated means
you've received two doses you have had
your post shot
uh two week window etc
um so now what they're saying is a
maximum of 10 individuals who are fully
vaccinated
can be in the draft room and if all
individuals are in the draft room
masks will not be required physical
distancing will be relaxed and eating
and drinking will be permissible
and that means that anyone who has the
vaccine
is allowed to be in the draft room and
it's going to look like they used to
right so i think that's you know sort of
a significant thing and the nfl
has gone a very long way to try to
employ people please
get the vaccine uh please give action i
know a lot of nfl personnel people are
so this is just sort of another push in
that direction
and then now when you think about in how
many guys truly can the nfl
i guess invite or who will they try to
invite obviously the quarterbacks is
always something that
people want to see those are the eye
catchers in terms of being
in that green room but how many players
you think overall
would probably accept an invitation to
go down to the draft
sounds like it's going to be a handful
so maybe and i don't know this for sure
but maybe 10 maybe 15
and you know those players we'll see
you know one thing we've learned in
covet is that a week is a long time
so a month or a month or more is a
really really long time
so we don't know what the regulations
for vaccination are going to be like
then i mean it might be possible for
players who are there um
you know to be fully vaccinated by that
point and then in which case you're fine
but
you are going to get you know let's say
10 or so
in in cleveland and then um
you know the other thing you're going to
have is something we saw last year
during the draft which is a lot of
cameras and houses
so people hang with family you're going
to see people's homes you're going to
get to see
you know who the mom is and the dad and
the high school coach and the girlfriend
or the wife and
all the stuff that makes the draft fun
you're going to get to see that in a lot
of homes as well
nfl networks ian wrap report joining the
rich eisen show kirk morrison here
in for rich make sure you follow ian on
twitter as well
at rap sheet is his twitter handle um
kind of browsed through twitter a little
bit ago i saw that the chicago bears
they tweeted out
a picture of their qb1 and it wasn't
russell wilson
right it was andy dalton
i'm trying to figure it out like are
they trying to tell us something that
we're supposed to wrap our arms around
andy dalton if
you're a chicago bears fan or is this
just all a little bit of smoke
before we get ready to get to this draft
where they draft the quarterback who
they think
can lead this franchise for the next
what 10 to 15 years
yeah i mean i i i had thought ever since
they told andy dalton he was quarterback
number one when they signed him i had
thought this was probably going to be
this way i mean and then
you know them saying qb1 for andy dalton
does
does make you think that you know it's
going to happen i mean
no one has said to me russell wilson is
definitely 100
not getting traded right um i thought it
was unlikely but no one has said a
hundred percent
um so i mean this is sort of further
solidifies
i mean the bears are moving forward with
andy dalton do they take someone in the
draft
possible uh they have a long way to go
sort of the problem
right like they'd have to someone would
have to fall for them or they have to
make a big trade back up
and it's interesting too because you
have a general manager and a coach who
are
you know in a situation where they have
to win this year would the organization
let them go
all in to make a big trade up for a
quarterback
i don't know um a lot of intrigue with
the bears but it does seem like they're
moving forward with andy dalton
you know it was a lot going on over the
last what i would say three to four
weeks in terms of
russell wilson in the seattle seahawks
and would russell be the qb one for the
chicago bears and now we know that
russell wilson currently
is a member of the seattle seahawks how
does this still end up playing out
though ian is there
still something that could go down
towards the draft it seems that
that talk has sort of cooled when it
comes to russell wilson and obviously
the teams that
were throwing out their teams that he
would go to have kind of filled their
positions at quarterback
yeah and you know i i think one thing
you've seen is
uh he has not uh sort of updated his
list he has not expanded his list he
hasn't said you know what
right i could go anywhere if he said
that
you know teams would be interested you'd
have teams who have really good draft
picks who might actually be
um you know desirable for seattle to
work with like the jets for instance
they might get in the mix potentially
but he hasn't expanded his list
he gave a list of four teams and that
was
basically that so you know if he gets
traded i don't see where
but what i do think this does is kind of
put the pressure on seattle to say you
got to improve things this year
otherwise you know we're probably going
to go through this again
next off season and at that point um
that would be for real
we saw aaron rodgers restructure his
contract with the green bay packers
um what does this now lead for him
obviously the cap number in 2021
the highest in the nfl i believe a 37
uh plus million dollars against the cap
over 20 percent
of the green bay packers salary cap for
this season
is this just a basically a one-year deal
or how are we seeing
the green bay packers and they navigate
these waters with aaron rodgers
well you know what what we've seen with
the packers and aaron rodgers is a
little bit of a standoff something
that's you know really happened the last
couple days
last couple weeks actually where you
know i know they'd like him to
kind of restructure his deal he has not
wanted to and mike silver has
my colleague has done some reporting on
um just sort of rogers wants to make
sure that he is
um wants to make sure that he is there
for the foreseeable future doesn't want
to do anything
that's going to make it so they can move
on from him and in a way
i sort of understand it because we've
seen you know tom brady plays till he's
40 drew brees plays three scored i'm
sure and rogers is going
can i like why why are you trying to get
rid of me just because you dropped soul
in the first round doesn't matter so
you know that's been a little bit of a
standoff and what it also did was
kind of stop the packers from making any
moves in free agency which is a whole
other
different interesting issue you know one
of the things too and i'm
just kind of looking at looking at a
picture there of aaron rodgers going
against the tampa buccaneers in that nfc
championship game but
as you look at what the buccaneers have
now done this off season it seemed they
bring the whole gang back
obviously they signed endowment consul
the other day to kind of bring back that
nucleus back
and you see now that tom brady and what
he's done in less than
what almost a full calendar year how
he's changed not only with that
franchise looks the way
people view that franchise how much does
that influence you think
maybe in aaron rodgers or maybe another
quarterback out there to say you know
what i kind of want to get some of this
total power not total power but some of
this influence that tom brady may have
over an organization
yeah i think a lot of big-time
quarterbacks kind of looked at that and
they're like wait a minute like
if i just have a little more say in
personnel they could just bring in the
guys that i want
and you know it's a it's an all-in
approach and
you know at some point the bucks will
kind of get the other side of it where
they've
given a lot of money they've created cap
space they've kicked it down the line at
some point that will all catch up with
them
i just don't know when i mean we've been
saying it's going to catch up with the
saints forever and it hasn't they're
still signing guys
right so i don't know i mean i i think a
lot of quarterbacks looked at that and
said
it's unfair that brady gets to do what
he wants and i don't
um so you know that maybe that did lead
to some of this where
guys like russell wilson and you know
um maybe aaron rodgers said i should
i deserve this say also just like tom
brady gets in tampa
i was i want to stay right there in that
same division in
the nfc south because tampa bay we
already know what's going on with them
they've already got theirs
already taken care of carolina still
trying to figure out maybe the
quarterback situation we'll see when the
draft comes along
i look at atlanta they seem to be pretty
firm with matt ryan
but then there's a new orleans saints
and they resigned jameis winston
obviously takes some heel signs the and
i know you can't see this but i got my
air quotes up
the four years 140 million dollar
contract by the way
um but it's taysom hill versus jameis
winston
and for right now everyone's saying that
this is kind of jameis's job to lose and
but
when you look at taysom hill is this
truly going to be a competition in new
orleans
uh well first of all the the taste and
health contract was fake that was right
actually it was just
that's what i had my air quality
so i mean i i think it's gonna be a
competition but to me
it feels like james winston has the leg
up there i mean he's the guy
who i know they liked him a lot last
year they loved how he was in practice
they left him in the building
he worked hard he cares about it the
only thing you don't know is when he
gets on the field is he going to limit
the interceptions
is he going to make smarter decisions
and there's just you just can't tell in
practice
so i really think i mean this might be a
situation where the preseason games are
actually important this year we're going
to have them again it sounds like so
preseason games might be important where
it's going to show the saints like did
jameis really learn
is he going to make smart decisions is
he going to be a sound decision maker
if that's the case i think he probably
will be the starter and sean payton is
such a good coach
such a good offensive schemer you know
this could be a career resurrection for
james
nfl networks ian rappaport in the at
rap sheet on twitter so ian i know
you're down there in the building trying
to
you're hearing what's going on down
there at the nfl network you're hearing
these pro days right
guys are ripping it up i see you just
posted about the micah parsons 4340 that
the linebacker from penn state yeah
where could he go in the top ten if you
look at what devin white did
and uh for the tambi buccaneers how he
was a force but
mack jones a quarterback of alabama had
an impressive day
uh at his pro day for alabama obviously
we saw trey lance a quarterback at north
dakota state
like what are you starting to hear now
that we're getting a chance to see these
players they're out there performing
they're working out
they're impressing what's been the buzz
so far as we start to get ready for the
draft
well i think the main thing i hear is
the quarterbacks are going to go early
i mean it's sort of always the case
right if a quarterback is the 25th best
prospect he probably gets drafted 10th
right i mean right
we've seen that history shows people
will trade up for a quarterback and
it's just they they stop they start
getting antsy and they say you know what
i don't care
i'm just gonna i'm just gonna do it i
expect that this year i mean we could
see
four quarterbacks in the top ten you
know something like that which is great
news for
basically everyone else because if you
like another player
an offensive tackle or a pass rush or a
corner a couple top corners
you know one of those guys gets pushed
up one of those guys
could get past the top ten when in
reality he shouldn't be because the
quarterbacks all get over drafted
so i think the quarterbacks are going to
go really early which will be a lot of
fun and then other than that it'll be
everyone jocking around for kind of who
is their favorite
you know at a position of need or a
position of high value
you know one of the last couple things
for you here ian is i was kind of joking
with the guys a little bit earlier i
said what's going on with you davey and
kleine remember it was just
a little while ago where he was a
franchise player
obviously he signs with seattle and
didn't resign with them he signs with
tennessee last season
only plays what eight games and now he's
sitting out there on the free agent
market
is he still a bargain for a team right
now currently or is he's kind of sitting
out hoping to get another big
big one-year deal possibly well i'm sure
it's going to be a one-year deal
what's interesting about clownie is he
turned down three years 57 million from
the browns last year
wow you know obviously should have
probably should have taken that um
in hindsight of course but you know he
what he wanted to do is
not limit his his earning value he
wanted to make sure that
he could go out have a great year last
year and then cash in this year
did not happen of course um so it's
probably gonna take a one-year deal with
the browns had a lot cheaper and i know
that
you know they really wanted to just sit
down with him
get to know him talk to him see what
makes him tick in a way that they just
were not able to do that last year
because
it just didn't didn't lend itself to
that situation right so they got him in
the building they talked to him sounds
like he went well
nothing is imminent but i know they they
liked what they heard we'll see the two
sides and get together and make a deal
hey ian always man i appreciate the time
i know you got a lot going on man but
appreciate you uh sharing a couple
minutes with us today
all right always a pleasure man take
care i appreciate it that's the nfl
network's ian wrap report at rap
sheet on twitter is his twitter handle
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here